hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
whenever we talk about complexity which
we do very often here at mindscape
whenever we talk about complexity as a
concept there's a question that is being
begged which is is there enough
coherence and consistency and
commonality between different
manifestations of complex systems to
legitimately talk about a field called
complexity I mean there are things in
the universe that are complex but do
they share enough ideas between them or
features between them that it makes
sense to abstract from the individual
things to talk about complexity as its
own field of study so today our guest is
David krakauer who is president of the
Santa Fe Institute Santa Fe is as you
probably know is the world's leading
Research Institute into complex systems
you'll not be surprised to say that when
faced with this question David says yes
there is enough commonality between
complex systems to study complexity but
after that it was very interesting
because I've known David for a while you
know I'm a part-time faculty at Santa Fe
but his definition of complexity and how
he thinks about it was a little bit
different than what I expected you know
not to give away too much but he really
puts the ability of complex systems to
in some sense reflect the world around
them to carry some information inside
them about the rest of the world and
adapt to it as a central defining
feature of complexity which is
fascinating to me because many
discussions of complexity start with
purely physical systems that don't do
that
hurricanes are supposed to be a
paradigmatic complex systems and David
is very clear he says nope I don't I
don't count that and that has very
interesting implications for all sorts
of things down the line so it's a
wide-ranging conversation with a lot of
name-dropping David knows the history of
this field in and out so you'll hear a
lot of names I encourage you to Google
them either while listening to the
podcast or afterward but the field does
have a fascinating history and thinking
about the questions that our
predecessors faced is often very helpful
in thinking about the questions we face
right now David started as an
evolutionary biologist and he still does
that but he is someone who absolutely
walks the walk in terms of being
interdisciplinary in the best possible
way this is something that makes sense
if if you have this complexity lens to
look at the world through
David has made very interesting
contributions not just to biology but to
uh social systems to purely mathematical
logical computational puzzles to
questions like how do we think about
covid and other pandemics from a complex
systems perspective what is the origin
of Life what is the nature of
intelligence how does artificial
intelligence fit into all these things
far more topics than we could possibly
cover in just a single short podcast but
David is all sorts of uh presence in
podcasts elsewhere so you can follow
them if you're already familiar with his
work let me throw in the occasional
reminder that here at mindscape you can
become a patreon supporter going to
patreon.com Sean M Carroll doing that
both makes me feel good it also makes
you feel good and you get the ability to
listen the podcast ad free and also ask
questions at the monthly ask me anything
episodes so it's a good thing to do
trying to build a community of people
who can talk to each other over at
patreon so look into that if you want to
support mindscape just a little bit and
with that let's go
[Music]
David krakauer welcome to the mindscape
podcast great to be with you I guess the
natural first question to ask here would
be what is complexity I'm sure you've
had that question before but instead let
me ask is there such a thing as
complexity I mean there are obviously
complex things but are those things that
are complex possessing enough traits in
common that it's worth having a field
called complex system studies yes yes
yes
I mean in a nutshell
we study teleonomic matter we study
matter with purpose and that's what
distinguishes it from physics
um the way I like to say it I mean just
briefly and we'll get into this I hope
is if the origins of modern physics or
at least mathematical natural science is
a scientific revolution of the 17th
century
the origins of complexity science are
the Industrial Revolution
the era of design the era of machines
both made by humans looms clocks
steam engines but also evolved and all
of the ideas that were embryonic uh in
that period have been developed up
through our own time so somewhere
between
statistical mechanics and evolution and
democracy you get complexity emerging
out of that yeah well interesting I
hadn't had the social Dimension but you
easily could for me the four legs of the
table
are
are statistical mechanics entropy
evolution
um control in other words well and
that's sort of worth talking about and
computation and all of that emerges
essentially in a period between 1840 and
1870. and that you know I'm I have in
mind people like Bull and Babbage and
Maxwell and Russell Wallace
and Darwin and so forth and all of them
all of those ideas that were there in
embryo what we're now flashing out
as you know I'm interested in the social
Dimension as well as other things but uh
that's that's yet for another podcast it
is interesting
um well so I want to get into the
history but given that I knew you were
going to say yes when I asked is there
something called complexity
okay now I can ask what is it like what
are the features that we have in mind
when we think about complex systems yeah
so the the
important point is to recognize that we
need a fundamentally new set of ideas
where the world we're studying
is a world with endogenous ideas right
we have to theorize about theorizers
and that makes all the difference and so
Notions of agency or reflexivity these
kinds of words we use to denote
self-awareness or
um what does a mathematical Theory look
like
when that's an unavoidable component of
the theory I mean Feynman and Murray
both made that point you know imagine
how hard physics would be if particles
could think that is essentially the
essence of complexity and whether it's
individual minds or collectives or
societies
it doesn't really matter
um and we'll get into why it doesn't
matter but for me at least that's what
complexity is the study of chileanomic
matter that's the ontological domain
and of course that has implications for
the methods we use and you know we can
use arithmetic but we can also use
asian-based models right in other words
um I'm not particularly
restrictive in my ideas about
epistemology but there's no doubt that
we need new epistemology for theorizers
I think that's quite clear you mentioned
Murray that's of course Murray Gilman
who played a huge role in founding the
Santa Fe Institute after after a long
career of kind of poo pooing anyone who
was not doing elementary particle
physics
yeah but you see that there are yes as
you know we both knew him well there
were two Murrays yeah
um there was the Mario physics the
phenomenologist
and then there was the Murray hoarder
collector taxonomist
natural historian of coins ties right
and birds
and and that and that's where his
complexity interest started to emerge
um in his obsession with the profusion
of diversity in those cultural and
biological domains it's interesting
though that you are emphasizing this
teleological aspect of things I mean I
would have thought that something like
the Milky Way galaxy could be thought of
as a complex system are you carving
things out so that that doesn't count or
are you just pointing at one of the most
Salient features of complexity is that
there's this sort of reflectiveness the
system we're studying is as complex as
we are no I don't think it counts I
think it's not useful
um there was in the early days
at SFI this desire to distinguishing
complex systems and complex adaptive
systems and I think that's just become
sort of irrelevant and in order for the
field to stand on its own
I think we have to recognize
that there is a shared very particular
characteristic of all complex systems
and that is that they internally encode
the world in which they live and uh
whether that's a computer or a genome in
a microbe or neurons in a brain
that's the coherent common denominator
uh not you know self-organizing patterns
that you might find for example in a
hurricane or a Vortex or those are very
important elements but they're not
sufficient okay that's that's actually
very interesting and I did not know that
you would say that because
self-organization obviously plays a huge
role as one of the first phrases that
comes to mind when you ask many people
about complexity so do you is the stance
that you just described uh heterodox
within the field or is this the emerging
consensus well I mean again I mean it's
worth talking about the history because
um you know where does the word come
from in the first place and I don't mean
the etymology of the word complexity
which would be slightly tiresome but its
use in the sense that we deploy it right
and the the original paper that was
influential on us is the 1948 one Weaver
paper which is called complexity in
science and in that paper Weaver makes
this interesting distinction between the
Sciences of Simplicity which is what you
have studied most of your career Sean
um that is the physical world
um The Sciences of what he called
disorganized complexity statistical
mechanics
and then organize complexity which is
life and
um he actually goes so fast to point out
that he thinks that the appropriate
methodologies there will be computation
it's quite prescient in 48 okay given
that no one had a computer or unless
you're a large government so there's
that there's another paper
um written in in 62
by herb Simon the architecture of
complexity and that you might know a bit
better and in that paper
it's the system's view of complexity
quite unlike the Weaver view which has
to do with in some sense Frozen
accidents and this balance between order
and disorder in this diamond perspective
it's about systems of partially
decomposable hierarchies of functional
units and that for him was complexity so
between Simon and Weaver if you just add
komogorov 68 which was algorithmic
complexity which is the two the Simon
and Weaver world is incompressible and
requires algorithms with long
description lengths then you get
essentially in a nutshell uh what we now
think of as the complex domain that okay
that's very very helpful the the history
is something that uh I need to learn
more about When I Was preparing for this
podcast I did stumble across a map of
the the timeline of complex systems
research are you familiar with this map
I I am I don't much like it but yeah I
am familiar with it yeah it was helpful
there were a lot of names there because
you know you when we were emailing back
and forth you listed some names about
half of which I recognized so I had to
look out to see where the other names
fit in but the Weaver thing let's let's
dwell on that a bit because it's one of
my favorite talking points the idea that
if you have a system uh I just think
about a cup of coffee right cream and
coffee mixing together and and thinking
about the entropy of it if it's very
very low entropy and organized it can't
be complex there's just not enough room
to move around and if it's very very
high entropy and disorganized it also
can't be complex because it's it's
already smeared out in equilibrium and
complexity lives in between is that a
point first made by Weaver in the 40s
yeah as far as I know I don't know if he
was the first but he certainly made that
point very clearly and of course it was
taken up by the sort of the Brussels
School in prison Jean's work on
dissipative systems that sort of as you
say these Tran long-lived transients
that seem to defy Boltzmann's intuitions
about the second law and I think it was
Phil Anderson in 72 who told us why that
wasn't complexity and the point being
that he he wrote extensively on this
topic actually which was you need to
somehow balance diversity chaos
structure
um with stability and if you're going to
do something adaptive computational
inferential functional you need a memory
you need to store information somehow
and that means you have to capture it
from the environment and store it and I
think one of the limitations as you say
of these um interesting transient
structures that you observe in your as
your uh you know cortado
cools down is that they're not very good
at storing information and they they
want to go the way they want to go they
have their own preferred structures
right and you'd have to establish very
fancy boundary conditions to produce
anything of really lasting interest so
Phil's point was somehow that has to be
condensed into some kind of equilibrium
structure uh so as to store information
reliably and so yes but it's a if you
like it's a kind of fancy initial
condition before you get to complexity
so I was going to ask about the word
adaptive in the phrase complex adaptive
systems because I have the feeling that
in let's say the 90s in the early days
of SFI uh it was just part of the phrase
complex complex adaptive systems but it
seems to have dropped out a little bit
and I was wondering whether or not there
was less emphasis on that but maybe what
you're saying is that now we just take
it for granted that of course reciting
adaptive systems yeah I think it's the
latter I think it's the latter I mean
one thing for us to chat about I think
is really important it's it's actually a
paper I mentioned to you that I'm
writing which is you know from action
principles in physics to adaptation and
complex systems through to agency and I
think that's quite a natural progression
uh and it solves this problem that I've
driven the absolutely batty over the
years where people say well why is a
ball not rolling down a hill adapting
and it's so frustrating that we have to
just put that to bed and you know we all
know right from physics about the
relationship between differential
equations of motion and you know
extremizing some functional uh to derive
our the fixed points of our of our
action and this is the whole basis of
the beauty of physics right the path of
light and the path of objects through
space and so on from a persius LaGrange
Hamilton schwinger
um adaptation is not an action and one
of the things that happened in the 40s
which is worth reflecting on is the
landscape metaphor was introduced to the
study of
um you know organized complexity as we
in the Weaver Language by Sewell Wright
and Waddington
the Adaptive landscape which I'm sure
everyone who's listening knows and this
is this idea instead of having a ball
that rolls down a hill you have a ball
that rolls up one and uh you know each
point in that landscape defines a
fitness and the maximum Fitness is what
natural selection takes you to and it's
rubbish and a wrong picture of a complex
system because it's not a ball rolling
on a landscape it's a map that's being
drawn of a landscape and one of the
characteristics of complex systems
is if you open them up they have a
memory right it's not a ball you can
read off from the internal states of the
system where it's sitting and
um that adaptation
is a if we think about it in terms of
mutual information for example it's the
information extracted from the world
so as to allow an organism to navigate
some configuration space and this ball
rolling on a hill metaphor which came
from physics has been very unfortunate
uh because it's led to this confusion
between action and adaptation but I kind
of like the fitness landscape I never
thought of it as a ball rolling on it
because obviously whatever was wandering
through the landscape gets to the top of
the hill and stops there am I allowed to
still have the landscape even though I
get rid of the balls yeah you should
have the landscape but a better version
of it would be shown with a map rather
than a ball and as you're navigating
through the landscape you're improving
your map
that's what adaptation is
um in every case that we've ever studied
that information is acquired and stored
hence Murray's Obsession and John
Holland with schema which were these
internal encodings of the world in which
an Adaptive agent lives there's no
avoiding it and I think that the the
abstraction into
this variational picture has has cost us
quite a bit of confusion I I would would
have guessed that somewhere in the first
few minutes of this discussion we would
have had words like power laws and
networks and hierarchies but you haven't
quite used those terms yet well I don't
use them very much
you know it's there well okay so there's
a lot to say here
um let's just be clear right that we and
see whether you agree there is a domain
which I think we have to accept which is
this domain of Agents
um that either evolved or we made them
um in one way or another
and they're hard to theorize about
because they theorize
and it turns out that um they have some
characteristic architectural features
hence the value of networks for studying
them so neurons in the brain are
connected in large networks and as are
individuals in societies who trade in
markets and so forth so networks feel
like a quite natural way of capturing
higher order correlations in the domain
of complex systems but they're just one
mathematical method yeah and um there
are many others and power laws are all
over physics they're also all over
complex systems they're all over the
universe so the there is this fetish I
think sometimes with
um methodologies and
um there's nothing wrong with that
because you know we all love mathematics
and it's powerful but we shouldn't
somehow
confused the map with the territory we
shouldn't um
belabor our tools
um to the exclusion of the richness of
the phenomenology because of course you
know as the science develops Sean we'll
develop new tools of course yes no and
so I don't there is a tendency I think
in the complex systems world to list
things oh yeah and
these networks agents and they're noisy
and they're distributed that's true but
you know there are many things in the
universe that are and I feel that as
long as all of that is in the service of
trying to understand these complicated
little computational elements
that we're theorizing about and
um that that for me it would be my
priority rather than the methodologies
that's completely Fair um Let me let me
back up a little bit to ask a
pre-question here which is would you say
that complexity science is
pre-paradigmatic in Thomas goonsense
like it we're more like Galileo than
Newton we have not agreed on a central
set of results and methods an example
well I think we well I don't know it's
it's that's an interesting question I
think that
um I don't think that's true I think
that going back to our history
um let's just talk about that because I
think it does establish the paradigm
um you know when the steam engine was
built we got very concerned about his
efficiency
hence thermodynamics that's a story I
know yeah right but not just
thermodynamics because watch had stolen
from Huygens the centrifugal governor
and installed it on the steam engine to
regulate
you know the speed of the engine
or its consumption of energy sources of
energy
and Maxwell invented control theory in
his famous 1868 paper
on regulators and governors which is you
know the original beautiful
um treatment of the stability of the
integral controller and the instability
of the differential controller so we
have control theory and we have
thermodynamics and statistical mechanics
okay
Carno clausius boltzmann Maxwell at the
same time
you have Russell and Darwin developing
the theory of natural selection and what
do they use to illustrate the principle
what's Governor there's a line at the
end of their paper where they say
natural selection and and I think
verbatim they say is exactly equivalent
to a governor which is okay so that this
is surprising he drops that Darwin by
the way in the Origin of Species this is
the presentation to the Nayan Society
um at the same time you have bull
writing the laws of thought right
developing his what we now think of as
Boolean logic it's not quite what we now
think of billion logic and you have
Babbage essentially conceiving of the
difference in and analytical engines
that the calculator and the computer all
of them are in correspondence
so
um so it's that conjunction of ideas
that pertain to
purposeful machines
is the paradigm and um so it comes out
of engineering as as I see it at least
now a hundred years later
those ideas are really Consolidated and
I mean by people like Vena right Veena
who discovers Maxwell Maxwell's paper
was considered too complicated it came
out of his early work by the way on the
stability of Saturn's rings so he was
interested in these General issues
um but that paper is quite complicated
but beautiful
um you've got Shannon you've got Turing
I mean all of them now really doubling
down on what we mean by computation what
we mean by information what we mean by
feedback control
and the development of the mathematical
theory of evolution by Wright Fisher
holdain and so forth so I do consider it
a paradigm what odd about it actually
Sean is it wasn't really until the late
60s and 70s
the the four if you like the four legs
were recognized as being part of one
table right and and that was people like
Phil Anderson to my mind
um who really pointed that out and so
yes it's a paradigm okay so you know the
the reason why I'm asking is because
this
distinction that you're drawing the the
the pudding of what what is a single
word description for what we're putting
Central here uh that that describes
carrying around a little model of the
world in you I call it chileanomic
matter I'm helenamic that I could carry
on a little model of the world without
having a goal right
uh you could have a record or a simple
Archive of the world but I don't think
so I mean to be purposeful in complex
reality
but okay but but okay anyway but I get
it
um I guess so you're carving that out
and I maybe the physicist in me wants to
say yeah but all this stuff about power
laws appearing everywhere and uh
preferential attachment and galaxies and
hurricanes and and that their
relationship to things like the second
law and Chaos Theory and things like
that is still all really important and
should count as complexity and maybe
this is just two sub-domains within
complexity that's why I'm asking if it's
paradigmatic or not I mean I grew up as
a physicist you grew up as a biologist
uh and yeah we're we're still our
history's man yeah I would say it's
interesting
I think that maybe Thomas was a
little bit too simple-minded
um maybe we don't really have paradigms
replacing paradigms but nested paradigms
because I agree with you I mean I think
just look at the one beautiful example
that I know we're both interested in
which is the
um development of the idea of the second
law as a statistical law that can be
locally violated yeah and
um Maxwell's demon you know through Lord
Kelvin describing it as an intelligent
demon by the way which is an
articulation of natural selection
um through which is a large paper in the
1920s saying it's all okay through
landauer through Bennett and I think if
you look at that history
of the development of statistical
mechanics to being a kind of statistical
mechanics of computation
at least in the way that Landau and
Bennett describe it right erasing bits
and all that
um then I think you're right I think
there are really interesting Bridges
between modern statistical mechanics and
complexity science because they already
have that sort of weird purposeful
character by virtue of the the demon and
um so I don't deny that but I I I just
want you to clarify this point that I
don't consider having an action
principle
equivalent to having an agent good I
mean just to back up for the for the
audience members who don't fall asleep
thinking about these things because I am
writing about them in the books that I'm
writing right now you know we have the
laws of physics which in the Newtonian
or laplacian way of putting things say
you give me the state at one moment in
time I can chug forward in time using
equations but we also have these
principles that say if I consider all
the possible histories and future paths
that a system could take the ones that
they physically do take minimize some
quantity and that sounds very Global and
very different but in fact it's exactly
mathematically equivalent as you're
saying and that I guess neither one of
these moves really works for a complex
system as long as we have incomplete
information right yeah that's right I
mean no one has really succeeded in
writing down an action functional I mean
you can try and there are
efforts if you think about you know
different formalizations of What's
called the action perception loo the
most recent popular version being the
free energy principle
um they do have that kind of variational
character
um even some of my work has shown
individuality maximizes something but
it's not clear that it's the stationary
solution to something and and I so in a
way for me I mean the reason why they
really fundamentally should not be
considered equivalent is because
one of them is essentially
leveraging ideas of conservation and
symmetry exactly right right whereas the
world that we live you know the complex
world we live in is all about broken
Symmetry and uh Frozen accidents and
because of that at best it would be a
sort of weak metaphor I found it very
frustrating to kind of go to the
Internet and look up principles of
Maximum entropy and minimum entropy
because there's all sorts of principles
that say sometimes entropy is maximized
sometimes it's minimized we're not
exactly sure when I'm not quite sure
what the usefulness of this these ideas
are but I still feel there's probably
something there I just haven't put my
finger on it yet yeah I I completely
agree and I think that it's like
everything right that you you have to
operationalize the concept and once
you've done that you're Tethered to
reality in a way that it's useful I
think if you're talking these very
generic terms I think many people do
I'm not exactly sure either what uh what
is being said well I'm really glad that
you mentioned Maxwell's demon though
because that is another one of my
favorite talking points and uh I'm not
sure if if the listeners know how it
took many many many decades to come to
some viewpoint on what the right
explanation for I'm gonna assume people
know what Maxwell's demon is so you see
how a little demon that can seemingly
violate the second law by separating hot
atoms and cold atoms it took us a long
while to figure out how maybe that's not
really violating the second law and even
now people don't agree I'm not quite
sure that we're completely done but one
way or another
I I wouldn't call it violating the
second law but it is a paradigm for many
kinds of complex systems right uh
something that uses free energy to keep
things more organized than they
otherwise would you think that's fair
oh absolutely I do and I and as you know
this is something I've worked on quite a
bit and I
um just to extend your explanation
um what's quite clear is that if you
think about Maxwell's demons as a
mechanism of sorting as you said between
hot and cold particles
um if you turn that little thought
experiment on its head you can think
about natural selection as edema that
sorts between alternative variants in an
environment and what is added to the
complication of this story
in complex systems is we what is the
origin of the demon itself exactly see
where right when when Maxwell and Lord
Kelvin were thinking about it it was a
sort of a gedankan it was like okay
here's how you can violate the
statistical law and then it turns out
well I was like no the demon is actually
you know dissipating he too and so on
and so forth
um but in the biological domain if
you're going to play with demons which I
do and as many people do
um and they get cool different things
um then you have to account for their
origin and natural selection is a very
interesting Collective demon I mean
certainly there's a physical Dimension
to Natural Selection if you're a bird
and you're flying it's not another bird
that's keeping you in the air
um but for most of us and for most of
the structure that we care about it came
about through competition with other
living things
demons so we're all Mutual demons to
each other and developing that theory of
nested hierarchical demons has been of
an interest of mine and it turns out to
be difficult not unlike the difficulty
incidentally of your coffee metaphor
because
now let me see um I'm gonna maybe a
little bit more technical now and you
tell me Sean whether I will tell you
please be technical first we'll fix it
later
yeah which is the following right which
if you imagine a string a binary string
uh let's call each of those bits an
information bearing degree of Freedom it
does something the first bit tells you
to go left the second bit tells you
which door to open you know that kind of
thing and we know because of the second
law that if you lead that string alone
for long enough it'll just be all
shuffled it's randomized thermalize so
think about a genome it's like a string
and each of the bits is an information
bearing degree of freedom it encodes an
amino acid of a protein or binding site
or okay
um so for every bit that is transmitted
over many generations reliably something
has to inspect it and say stay that way
that's natural selection right but it's
not one demon you know it's a tree it's
an ant it's it's the amount of water in
your environment it's an incredibly
complicated composite of forces
inspecting each bit and turns out you
can prove this that the complication or
the description length of the target
sequence right cannot be greater than
the description length of natural
selection itself because natural
selection has to inspect each bit
right unless you can compress it if
there's redundancies you can and so you
get this really weird result which is
that
um organismal complexity agent complex
is upper bounded by the complexity of
natural selection itself and that's this
problem of the origin of the demon well
because you have to build this damn
thing right but you're going to need to
explain to me what we mean by the
um complexity of natural selection
itself I mean the the idea of natural
selection can be written in Haiku form
right I mean you must mean the are you
including the whole environment in which
the selection is happening yes well that
is natural selection right Sean that's
one of the slightly misleading things
about using the word natural selection
because it's basically every force in
the universe that intrudes upon each bit
that's information bearing so it's a
very misleading idea and in fact that's
partly one of the limitations of the
mathematics a little bit like the
limitation of the fitness landscape
because you can just write down this
thing and call it f sub I no process
simple but what is that thing and that
thing is everything right so another we
just make this clearer is if I gave you
a random string and I said to you Sean I
would like you to
flip the bits to achieve this Target
string and each time that was also
random you'd have to go through that
sequence bit by bit
flipping accordingly
your natural selection I'm the organism
so you can see there's this kind of
interesting problem hence the
development of ideas like ecosystem
engineering and Niche construction which
are efforts partial beyond belief
um to build natural selection itself the
origin of selection not the Origin of
Species so somewhere on my computer I
have a list of my future research
projects I don't know about you but I
always I conceptualize my future
research goals in terms of the titles of
papers that I will someday try to write
and and one of them is uh some of them
are very well fleshed out and some of
them are completely speculative in the
latter category we have how information
comes to life I want to know I think
this is exactly the question you're
asking what is the first moment in the
evolution of the universe and the life
within it where one part of the universe
was using information about another part
for some purpose is that something do we
know the answer to that one already
no okay no that's really interesting
it's um it's odd you know Chris campus
and I just wrote a paper called life is
problem solving matter and
you know this is a whole we can go down
this path but I think the way that
you're thinking about it is correct
because the way we typically think about
origin of life which is what you're
talking about
um is the origin of certain kinds of
chemistry which are correlated with life
right and so we often confound the
chemistry of life itself that life is
doing the thing you're describing which
is some weird inferential
representational thing and
um when that first happened I think
genuinely mysterious I I do think we've
been a little bit misled by an obsession
with Organic Chemistry
um and one thing to point out that helps
us is I think we've built life so many
times
as non-chemical Digital Life
um I think that if you write a little
code on your computer show on it it
could be very simple form of life
um but I think it qualifies and the life
is this weird thing just to use a um
a physics concept
which is things like two things I kind
of work on life and intelligence life I
consider intensive whereas intelligence
I consider extensive
um you're not moralized if you have a
hundred cells than one right right yeah
an elephant is not more alive than a
flea that that would be kind of silly
um but but you beneathon might be more
intelligent than a flea and there's this
very interesting connection between
those two concepts I don't think that
you can
um treat them independently I think once
you develop life you've developed
intelligence and vice versa and working
out that difference is is complicated so
I always just think about these things
in terms of entropy and the second law
and core screening and things like that
um the centrality of information to
everything that you've talked about is
is very clear and to me the big bang is
the ultimate information resource in
some sense it was very very low entropy
which is another way of saying that we
have a lot of information about exactly
what the state was and ever everything
ever since then is just exploring the
space of of possibilities and is it you
know I the the evolution of complex
systems you know I I think about these
simple ingredient organic ones you want
to think about the evolution of
teleonomic Agents uh is there a general
understanding of why they come to be at
all in that General working out of the
second law
no
um the the what there is
is a sort of tautological understanding
that once a replicator comes into
existence that can error correct it will
stay in existence you know what I mean
yeah so but that's not necessarily
um a sophisticated encoding of of the
world in which it lives and you we can
it's the sort of large language model
paperclip nightmare right it's that sort
of thing you can build lots and lots of
simple things and it's quite
straightforward but this move towards
um encoding something else that's
encoding
there are stories right
you know well look it's competitive and
if I can out encode you then you know
but there's stories and I don't I
genuinely don't know of any
um Theory I know of models but they're a
little bit too fine-tuned to my you know
for my tastes
um but I don't think there is a theory
that says that more and more
sophisticated
trillionomic agents should come into
existence I don't think there is such a
theory well part of it part of it is and
I talked a little bit with uh Michael
lockman at SFI about this questionnaired
to me one way of stating the puzzle is
at the level of just statistical
mechanics and Thermo and entropy there
is no future boundary condition in the
universe it doesn't the universe does
whatever it was it wants to do there's a
past boundary condition the low entropy
past Hypothesis Big Bang Etc but
purposeful agents can be thought of
maybe I don't know tell me if I'm wrong
as carrying a little mini future
boundary condition with them there is a
a state they want to be at in the future
and it almost doesn't matter how they
get there right like if I want to go to
the store maybe I you know take the car
or I walk or I take this path or
whatever the point is that future State
I want to be in so how in the world does
the uh big looming past boundary
condition of low entropy get flipped
around to little mini boundary
conditions in agents that have purposes
yeah and I I think it's a deep question
I genuinely don't think of good answers
to it I think that the I mean that to me
is you know going back to our earlier
point about action and adaptation to
agents I think agents introduced the
concept of the policy
um like a Markov policy meaning a
procedure
um or a route
um which is what you're talking about
and I think that if you think about
chemotax a bacterium that navigates up
some nutrient gradient to a Target it's
this differential controller I think
instantaneously the scalar field tells
me that I'm in the right place and I'm
going to wiggle about a bit and stop
once I get to a higher concentration and
so forth but that's not what we do right
we say you know I I want to go to the
shop and buy some orange juice right and
there is no gradient right there is no
information in some weird orange juice
scale of feel telling me I closer to
Whole Foods no sadly so I have a map and
and that transition from adaptation
simple adaptation to agency following a
policy is very intriguing
um no doubt we could build models where
you in some sense accumulate bits of
information that allow you to encode a
path but you know is there a theory for
that transition no okay
I think to ask more intelligent
questions we should get some stuff on
the table about emergence because yeah
you know you've talked about it a lot
I've talked about it a lot the word is
fraught so rather than trying to Define
it let me ask how you think about the
idea of emergence yeah and I and I'm
very indebted to Phil Anderson here and
um and and uh Bob Laughlin the yeah it's
one of those terms that for some reason
attracts a lot of bullshitty commentary
and um let me make start simple and get
more complicated perfect I think the
simplest place to start is where Phil
begins with symmetry breaking and that
is the underlying fundamental laws of
physics are symmetric
and so if you're trying to explain
why one particular stage is picked
rather than other where both would be
equally probable under the laws
um you have to invoke this idea that
asymmetry is broken either it's driven
or it's endogenously found by some
stochastic fluctuation and then there is
some energy barrier that keeps you in
that state and
um and the canonical examples always
given are the chirality of molecules
that whether they're left handed or
right-handed and amino acids are
l-chiral they're left-handed and sugar
is a d chiral they're right-handed and
they always are and so and there's no
law of physics that tells you that that
should be true because they're they have
enantiomers and so you should find as
many LSD you don't now so that's the
first point
um and of course as molecules get bigger
the tunneling barriers get deeper and so
these broken symmetries accumulate and
that's what marry like to call Frozen
accidents and the complex world is full
of them
and it's built up from them so the first
I think condition for emergence is
broken symmetry
because it already tells you that if you
want to understand the the observable
you can't use the physics doesn't tell
you and it's consistent with it it obeys
the physics but it's not dictated by the
physics to use his language which I
think is a very very important
distinction obey versus debate and um
and then of course as you move up it's
Natural Selections that's breaking all
the symmetries and um and so it's
obeying physics but dictated by
selection by these weird demons so okay
point one point two it turns out that
um in these hierarchy of Frozen
accidents turns out that you can write
down effective theories
not fundamental theories effective
theories for there for the observables
of interest for the effective variables
um that do as well as understanding all
the microscopic constituents and for
example you can write down a fluid
dynamical equation as opposed to a very
high dimensional description of all the
particles motions right and for me
broken symmetry is the physical
precondition for the possibility of
writing down effective theories and if
that effective Theory
is dynamically sufficient that is you
don't gain information by going down
even though it's clearly obeying those
laws that is what we mean by emergence
and
um it's not very complicated right it's
in the physical world and it's in the
complex World
um and what's fascinating is that
tune-inomic matter mobilizes emergent
levels to understand itself so we have a
concept of ourselves that we and we
mobilize our minds to understand it it
obeys brain Dynamics but I have no idea
what my neurons are doing and neither do
I care and and that extends up through
the disciplines and I like to give the
example of course of mathematics that
the proof of the correctness of a
theorem
like Andrew Wiles as proof of the fomat
conjecture does not depend on how much
endorphin he's generating
um it's expressed entirely in terms of
mathematics itself and when you can do
that why you're allowed to write down an
effective theory is why emergence is
interesting because you can't always do
it sure right because the right because
the range of parametric variation under
which that theory applies can be very
limiting and that's why I think it's an
interesting scientific problem as
opposed to just an inevitable one so
that version of emergence I think maps
on to the classic distinction of weak
versus strong emergence as weak
emergence you're you're talking about
core screening A system that could very
well be described at a microscopic level
but you don't need to and there's no
point in doing it right yes there are
people out there maybe you know some of
them who think that's that's not enough
who really think that we're going to
need new laws of physics
purely at the macro levels uh that then
influence via downward causation what's
happening at the micro level are you
against that or do you not need it
I'm against it and I'll explain why I'm
against it for the reasons of Phil was
which is it's greedy
um the those new laws of physics are
called English literature or uh musical
composition
or metaphysics right uh or carpentry and
it's not a new law of physics it's a new
Theory and it may have laws in it I'm
not sure might have rules in it might be
a little bit more modest
um but they're not physics anymore I
think physics ended once we moved into
the domain of excessive complication
still there it's never going away thank
God you know
um thank you whatever but uh it's not
very useful and um so I this is what I
mean by confusion the it's actually not
a complicated thing to him right I mean
we can write down these effective
theories we would like to know when we
can
um presumably there's some temperature
range where they apply right at a
certain point my mind isn't going to
work because the proteins are going to
denature of course yeah and then I need
to know about proteins uh so I have to
be a reductionist in in that sense
um but so fine it's it's it's it's a
science of pluralism it tells you why we
need to have Schoenberg and Jimi Hendrix
and not just Newton and leibniz so I
find that reassuring in all sorts of
ways
um now in terms of downward causation
you know
and I think Jessica's written about this
quite well and which I quite like uh
Jessica Flack when she talks about
the parts reading off the states of the
whole and um and that I think resolves
elements of the Paradox right which is I
can read one of your books
and be influenced by it um and all my my
mind is reading it as are my neurons and
um there's no mechanical mystery in that
anymore and that's downward causation
without mystery so what I'm thinking
about one of the reasons why I brought
up this question is we live in a world
where the space of possible Arrangements
of things is very very large right the
combinatorial uh set of possibilities is
beyond our comprehension and we live in
a very specific place in it there's
specific animals specific organ
um environments and so forth there are
those who would say that in order to
account for why this particular place we
live in right now is where we are
we can't just rely on microscopic
physics plus some random numbers we need
some principles or something to stretch
out over it I'm not I'm not doing this
position Justice because I don't have
the slightest belief in it but there I'm
not making it up either there are people
like this no I know and I and and I
think that the legitimate part of that
obscurantism is
um that we don't really understand as
we've already just we don't even
understand about the origin of Life as
we pointed out earlier so there are
genuine problems out there that need to
be resolved we shouldn't pretend we have
and but we don't want to fill it with
fill it with you know moonshine
um the
I do think though that we need a much
more sophisticated theory of memory and
of history and
um so when you talk about fluctuations
and so forth that's the whole point
about Evolution right that it it
incrementally builds up a more and more
refined encoding of reality it builds up
a memory and that's by the way the
connection to the igas and D coherent
histories and all that I mean there's
this uh we essentially encode course
grained representations of particular
trajectories in evolutionary history you
should explain what an igus is oh well
this is a little bit of a tribute to our
colleague and friend uh Jim hartle who
just passed away
um in the Quark in the Jaguar
Marigold man
presents a complex system in lines that
I share in terms of schema these little
entities that have that encode histories
that they use to behave and predict
um he doesn't go much beyond that
actually uh in that in that book we can
talk I mean and John Holland and talked
about this and in fact the first schema
theorem was presented by Emmanuel Kant
in the critique of pure reason it's a
whole chapter called the schema where
Camp was trying to understand how you
turned continuous sensation into
propositions such fascinating actually
another prehistoric contribution to
complexity
um and Murray then said let's call the
scheme on igus and um this is a an
abbreviation
um in information gathering utilizing
system
and I think Murray and now be very
curious to hear what you think about
this show because I think part of this
was motivated by his feeling very
disgruntled with Copenhagen and the role
of the Observer and all that weirdness
around the Consciousness versus just you
know yeah a detector
um and then Jim hartle
in in really delightful ways I think
extended the idea in two papers which I
really enjoyed one of them was why is
the universe comprehensible
getting an Einstein's question
and and the second one was what he
called the physics of now which was why
is there a present a past in the future
these are actually evolutionary sequeli
they are not part of physics they're a
part of complex systems and he used the
igus he put an igus in minkowski space
and said this is how it would operate
and derive these three concepts from
that and um anyway that's just done Jim
and the igus well I I this is always
dangerous to sort of speak
extemporaneously in the middle of a
podcast but maybe I can see that there
is a link between the questions that I
care about about increasing entropy and
how the journey from low entropy
equilibrium can look complex to the
points you raise about agency and
information and teleonomics because it
is probably just a generic feature of
interacting subsystems
along the journey from low entropy to
high entropy that they make an
impression on each other if I walk down
the beach I leave footprints on it now
the beach doesn't use those Footprints
to to do anything but I it might not be
that much of a leap to see how if both
of the interacting systems uh have
enough complexity they could they're
more likely to persist if they can put
that information to use yeah I mean you
can and I mean I've worked on these
models and it's not difficult to do if
you take the kind of model that you
worked on right the um which generate uh
non-trivial transient patterns and you
add to that gauss's principle the
so-called um Exclusion Principle which
is that if the local order is maintained
by some energy gradient
and I'm allowed to exclude you from that
position in space so as to gain access
to more of it that's
um that does increase the frequency of
these
um pattern States so Darwin called it
competition girls called it the
Exclusion Principle the so you can add
just a few tweaks to what would
otherwise be a fairly simple dynamical
system and produced in very long-term
states of order and now why they then
ratchet up right is is somewhat unknown
well I guess this this relates to what I
was going to ask next which is about the
you you already alluded to the fact that
you don't always have an emergent Theory
lying around right when you have some
collection of stuff you may or may not
be lucky enough to have a simple way of
describing it just in terms of
macroscopically observable features but
when you do well so number one what do
we know about when you do like how
generic are emergent descriptions are we
very fortunate to have them at all and
and number two I know that you've wrote
and written and spoken on the role of
noise in maintaining things like that
which is just fascinating to me you know
I know I know the dissipation and
friction are everywhere in the
macroscopic world but you're you're
giving the sales pitch for us making
them
um positive contributions to our
persistence rather than merely
annoyances yeah I mean that's um yeah
that was that so yeah that's Lots well I
won't mention my adversaries in that
debate story tell the story you can tell
it no but this was uh a debate that
David Bowen and I had with
um Danny kaneman and Kass sunstein and
and and and they had written this book
called noise and how terrible it is I
mean because Dan is written of course at
length about bias sure and um how we
should correct it and this sort of the
sequel was noise and how we should
correct it and and coming from
evolutionary theory where this sort of
cynical nun for the evolution of complex
life is mutation you know noise in other
words it seemed a little bit unfortunate
and then of course the more you look
um from you know stochastic resonance
stochastic amplification you know
equilibrium selection in games noise is
absolutely one of the most valuable
um characteristics of complex systems
and the if you want you can reduce it to
one statement which is exploration which
is that if you want to explore a space
noise is very handy
um but once you want to exploit a
solution you want to kind of turn it
down a bit and so it's this dielectric
right between high and low temperature
that is characteristic of the complex
domain so it's both constructive and
destructive but you want to be able to
control it and does it play a role in
when we have an immersion description
well I think it must write because
presumably
the origin of those new levels
um presumably are discovered through
some random walk of one kind or another
and
um and it's also the case right that
mutation is macroscopic noise I mean by
physics standards by biological
standards microscopic noise but um you
know this is not this is not noise in an
atom right this is this is noise in a
macromolecule and so
um so it's quite interesting how Nature
has built
noise in at levels above what we
normally think of as thermal noise
and um this is not the noise induced by
a slight increase in temperature even
though there are these original effects
yeah these are actually built they're
constructed
dot dice that we've loaded
um complex systems with in order to
generate variability in this whole
discussion of emergence not just today
but in in my life you know there's
always this issue that Concepts we kind
of take for granted are now things that
we're trying to explain and account for
like agency or purpose or or whatever
um I I just recalled one that you've
written about that I would love to hear
more about which is the existence of
individuals like how do we get to carve
up systems into this thing is a coherent
whole and and that one is a separate
thing you're you're not going to rely on
some fundamental Essence you're going to
say that's an emerging phenomenon yeah I
mean this interesting individuality
comes from two different directions
one is when I was at Oxford having to
listen to Richard Dawkins
um insist that the only unit of
selection was a gene and his argument
being
that it's the only temporally coherent
structure it's the thing that survives
recombination intact so when you Shuffle
the deck of cards
it's not the hand that's preserved it's
the cards right so that's the gene that
was his view
um and that seemed to me too
simple-minded and then on the other hand
this desire that we all have to find the
atomic building blocks of our
field of our domain so it could be a
quark it could be an atom right it could
be a molecule it could be a cell
and uh if you're interested in the
evolution of of complexity at least to
me one of them should be this weird
thing that we all take for granted which
is that the complex domain comes in
these packages that we call individuals
agents or organisms it's hard not to
find them right I mean thank you for
going what's going on yeah you know
are we just being misled is it nominal
is it a perceptual artifact
and all of that might be true right I
mean that might be true so with some
colleagues we started developing a uh
information theoretic formalism to hunt
for them right
could we develop if you like
lenses
like telescopes that work in different
electromagnetic frequencies
that would detect different kinds of
individuals a where the operational
definition is something that can
propagate adaptive information forward
in time an Adaptive World line that's
what we're looking for
and um and the answer was yes we could
we developed this Theory
um and the and you discover this kind of
zoo
of different kinds of a genetic atom you
know individual
um the one that we all know best the
organism which is defined largely in
terms of its own lineage right so to
understand Sean I should meet Sean's
parents and to understand them their
parents not being excessively Freudian
about it but simply seen it typically a
lot of it comes from them and the
environment but a lot from them
genotypically nearly all of it actually
all of it not epigenetically but
genetically
um and so you're this somewhat
autonomous thing that is largely
responsible for propagating your
information forward in time if you look
at things like social insects
well there the genetic information is
shared across different
physical units
right so ants and bees it might be that
the queen bee propagates the genome
the workers help her
um there there's a different conception
of individuality and it's a collective
one and so what these information
theoretic devices do is they find them
they say Ah that's the right level of
aggregation
uh which information is in some sense
being propagated forward it's it's
that's the that's a coarse graining
which is sufficient
um so
now having discovered them let's go back
to Richard Dawkins
what you realize right is that it's not
true that it's the most minimal building
block that is reliably transmitted
forward in time it turns out it's kind
of periodic the minimal Things Are
then the thing's a bit more inclusive or
not then things that are more inclusive
are right you see what I mean and so a
little bit like a society a society
probably propagates forward culture
quite reliably
if that's what you were measuring but
bits of it do not
and individuals might and so for us it
was just a much more
grounded attempt to discover
um the causal units of complex systems I
guess that's how I would say it so under
some circumstances is it right to think
of the ant colony as the individual
rather than the individual ants exactly
absolutely right you know I mean a
really good collaboration right so like
Jim Murray on on their Quantum cosmology
they are the individual uh and um
cutting it in half you would lose it and
um I think that's one of the things that
herb Simon was trying to talk about in
his two papers the architecture of
complexity and the organization of
complexity published in the 70s which
was
you have these Loosely bound things and
these tightly bound Aggregates and you
move between them and I think that's one
of the really fascinating
characteristics of complex systems that
you form these quite tightly bound
Aggregates that look physically Loosely
bound has SFI press ever published an
anthology of the most important Central
papers in the history of complex systems
well that must be yes I am publishing it
now you could you know that so we are
publishing uh on the 40th anniversary of
SFI which is next year foundations of
complexity science and these are papers
the first two papers are latke and
zillard 1920 1920s through to 2000 and
so I don't do the pre-history do the
history
and it's it's it's an extraordinary
um coherent
um project
the one of the things that we always
laugh about at SFI when we have meetings
and we're trying to hire people or
whatever or decide we would think oh my
God none of us agree on what complexity
is
it's just going to fission
but what's weird as you know right is
you sit down you think well very quickly
it's about adaptation
it's about computation it's about energy
all of these Essential Elements come
into play very fast and what we don't
have right is the and maybe never will
is the kind of unified theory of all of
those things that will justify it and
um I do genuinely believe that the
information energy integration is on the
horizon
um
The Evolution thing I don't know
um so yes so this is coming out and part
of my interest in this history is um
reading all of those pages
and seeing all how they rhyme yeah yeah
um I mean that's why I suspect that it
is paradigmatic I mean the thing about
having a paradigm is that maybe you're
not sure until the year passed
um because we're we we do seem to be the
Royal we certainly on the verge of
understanding some things you know
complexity science has taken more
seriously as a field than it was 40
years ago when SFI was founded and uh
not at every department at every
University but uh I think that it's it's
it's not a novelty and we're really
tying some threads together but maybe
I'm being overly optimistic no I think
you're right and one thing we haven't
talked about much I think you're right
is the social science Dimension because
at the founding of SFI
one of its peculiar characteristics and
that's why I sometimes describe it as a
midpoint between the Bauhaus and Bell
labs is that we had social science as
much in evidence As Natural Science but
we didn't make that distinction yeah and
um and that's because
coming out of the Austrian School
this interesting information computation
aggregation
um and then of course the early work of
canaro on learning and expertise and
then Brian Arthurs obvious were building
on on positive returns
um they were all talking about the same
kinds of things as the natural
scientists and computer scientists
Stuart Kaufman John Holland marry and
others
um all interested in schema-like
phenomena I guess is one way to put it
all interesting agents and they're
collectors and so that put us in a
really interesting position with respect
to the modern world because
if you look at things like covid climate
change inequality which are the
existential crises of the 21st century
um which we have to address
well you'd have to be an absolute idiot
to believe that you could solve climate
just knowing geochemistry right you it's
clearly a human problem as well it's a
policy problem it's a politics problems
economics problem so by virtue of our
interest in the synthesis of these
disciplines
we're almost in a unique position
actually I think
um to tackle problems that have that
character which is basically all complex
problems as far as I can tell and kovid
was the great wake-up call for people
because everyone thought you know we
listened to a fauci and it was
epidemiology and Immunology
but what was really happening on the
streets is
well my kids need to go to school
um or I need to make a living
I can't close my restaurant for two
years or and so on and so bringing all
those together in some rigorous way is
is not just intellectually interesting
it's existentially
urgent you know and I think it's your
point that's why this this the eye of
Sauron is now looking at us and others
like us to provide some answers all this
is as you've emphasized correctly I
think you know one of the fun but
challenging parts of complex systems is
that in physics you know we have
Collective Behavior but the individual
pieces that are collecting are pretty
simple themselves and in in society the
individual pieces are themselves complex
I had a great podcast uh with Jane
McGonagall I don't know if you know her
yes game designer right sorry computer
games yes that's right but she's
designed ways to use game-like things to
basically war game scenarios like
pandemics Etc and to discover features
of human behavior that you might not
have guessed in the in the model and uh
it's that's that's part of the
development of of tools you know we
didn't even talk about agent-based
modeling and uh other things but you did
mention that the idea that we would have
to use computers to simulate things was
there at the very beginning of this
whole complex systems talk yeah no I yes
I I um
I mean one of the interesting things
that's happening and I'm curious you
know we had um John Baez here recently
to give a talk right and his talk was
entitle something like the future
physics and it was quite amusing this
tool
um so he ends the first third of his
talk by saying there's nothing really
interesting happened in physics in
theory since 1980.
um fundamental Theory simply hasn't been
tested it's not that it's not being
developed but no new testable
predictions for merge that's the first
part of the short so let's give that up
the second part of his talk was anything
interesting happening now is in
condensed matter
and he talked about excitons and phonons
and you know effective particles
um and that's fun and then the third
part of his talk was what we really need
to be working on a physicist is
climate change via the economy right and
it was sort of slides that he pulled off
Wikipedia
um that he then presented back to us it
was kind of fun in in bringing coals to
new cars yeah I was going to say you're
right and I but I thought that was
telling that
um and I'd be curious to know how you
feel about this Sean now that you know
theoretical physicists who had a really
good run
um because it's so fascinating
mathematically logically and so
predictive and that sort of kind of over
where physics moves and um are you all
going to become complexity scientists
right so it's not over
um and and it's not true that there's
been no
the the statement there's been no major
progress in theoretical physics
fundamental theoretical physics since
1980 is adjacent to a true statement but
it is not actually a true statement I
mean there's been no model building that
correctly maps onto reality that we
didn't have in in 1980 you know still
general relativity and the standard
model of particle physics and the Big
Bang Theory
um enormous insights into the workings
of those theories and enormous insights
into
um possible speculative models Beyond
those theories I mean just the black
hole information problem all by itself
has been an enormous font of interesting
ideas holography and things like that
but this is a this is the subject of an
upcoming podcast so I'm not going to
give away too much right now but I
completely sympathize with the claim
that we've not made as much progress
um part of that I think is because the
first half of the 20th century was
absolutely unique in the amount of
progress we made in fundamental physics
and we got spoiled like it was so much
that the whole second half of the 20th
century could be used just fixing up
what we learned in the first half and
now now it's harder so but I absolutely
take the point that it's harder to make
progress in these areas and I think that
one I I've said this explicitly so I'll
say it again
there's three things we can do one is
keep trying you can keep proposing
models maybe the dark matter is this
maybe the hierarchy problem is solved by
that and maybe you get lucky you never
know like when Weinberg did electroweak
unification he didn't know it was even
very promising he got he got a little
bit lucky but he was smart enough to do
enough smart things he was going to get
lucky eventually the second thing you
can do is move into complexity science
or biophysics or Econo physics or
whatever you can move to other levels of
the hierarchy other than the fundamental
physics and I think that is part of what
I'm doing right but the other part of
what I'm doing which I also want to
plump for is you can take a step back
and think about the foundations of your
field you know we in that excitement of
the early part of the 20th century we
rushed past some really big things
um whether it's information Theory or
quantum mechanics or whatever that I
want to be a little bit more careful and
philosophical about and that is still
gives us room for major breakthroughs
you know it's it's so interesting to say
that because this has always been one of
those things that surprised me about the
way science Works
um if you think about Darwin's theory so
Darwin by and large an empirical
narrative account
and beautiful and amazingly but but
that's how it now get parts to get
mathematized using dynamical systems and
but now we have information Theory right
now we have very interesting theories of
computation we could go back
and just do it again
and instead of saying you know let's
just add episodes yeah which is what we
tend to do which is okay
um so this idea that science should
recreate itself historically from time
to time based on all sorts of progress
is really fascinating and I don't think
it's sufficiently done so I'm very
interested in that point well it's not
especially done I do want to mention one
little thing that I did which is
probably a paper you haven't read it's
not really in your uh list of things to
do but when you were talking about
individuals and how you know they
persist in in some way passing on
information from Generation generation
um I wrote The quantum mechanics version
of that
not about individuals but just asking
how can you carve up the world into
subsystems uh I mean we do in quantum
mechanics we treat the world as
subsystems and we glue them together but
we we take the subsystems as given we
don't ask ourselves the inverse problem
why did we carve it up that way and so
ashmeet Singh and I wrote a paper called
Quantum myriology muriology being the
relationship between holes and parts and
guess what they're like exactly like you
said for your uh information theory of
individuality there is a set of criteria
it has to do with entropy and there's a
thing you minimize and that tells you
where the subsystems are yeah no that's
right but again you know does this point
towards a greater unification and
um you know all their generalized
theories of ordered states that
transcend the living and non-living
worlds and as there are in the second
law I mean that's at the other end they
clearly are and so yeah I one of the
things I think has been fascinating to
me
in this as I've learned about complexity
science is
how this Aura boros turned back on
itself that the study of fundamentals
turns out to be genuinely valuable in
practice and when I was growing up
probably you too right it was look if
you're going to do fundamental stuff
you're in the South Pole but if you want
to do a Playboy you have to go to the
North Pole and it's a it's a long track
you know it's a long distance in a long
time yeah but what I've discovered and
this has been you know very reassuring I
think is that in in the domains that we
work it's not necessarily a very long
track you can tunnel well look and
Sergey Carnot wanted to build a better
steam engine that's right look at that
hence that exactly it so that's the
Industrial Revolution is such a
beautiful example because all of this
deliberation about the designed universe
is the progenitor to all we're
discussing today I do want to give a
last chance for a sort of grand
pronouncements on the future of
complexity but but the one thing I want
to get in here before we get to there is
intelligence because this is what you've
been thinking about and working on and
we've talked about agents and
individuals and the origin of them and
even purposes but we throw around words
like thinking and planning and and
processing and intelligence and
cognition and presumably within this big
framework that we've mapped out those
are also things that emerge along the
way how much do we know yeah so that's
sort of my core yeah research project
and
um and I guess I'm interested in it more
the way a physicist is interested in
these things because I'm interested in
it as a universal phenomenon as I am
with life right it's not I'm not
studying intelligence as a like a
psychologist would but um as an
inevitable feature of the universe
perhaps
um
I mean there's so much to say about this
I wouldn't know where to begin but um
the nowadays of course just you know
there's an elephant in the room and
that's large language models and Ai and
ashimelian and I just wrote a big paper
on large language models and our
conclusion without going through all of
that was that we need a much more
pluralistic attitude to what we think of
as intelligence and all it's kind of
constellation related Concepts like
meaning like understanding like
Consciousness
um I think my effort has been on the one
hand to demonstrate or to articulate
what is the general character and the
general character to me is basically
problem solving algorithms
um and that can be conscious or
unconscious and
the history of culture is the
amplification of that capability through
time we are more intelligent by virtue
of the culture we live in
um but we've reached this very
interesting moment where
tools have gone Rogue in going from the
slide rule and the Abacus to the HP 65
and which feigenbaum worked out you know
the bifurcation value with
um two large language models something
has happened in the world of cognitive
artifacts and my theory of this and I
again this is perhaps too much for now
is what I call a transition from
complementary cognitive artifacts like
slide rules and the Abacus which
genuinely amplify your capability with
or without them actually
um to a world of competitive cognitive
artifacts that exclude us from
deliberation and so intelligence has now
become as it was I guess at the
beginning of the 20th century
with Binet and you know Jensen and
Pearson and others working on iqjs and
all that nonsense
um we've returned to the ethics of
intelligence in the last I don't know
several months and uh and I think there
are General theories for this
uh in terms of the opacity of the
mechanism of action
um and so llms are like the GPS
and not like a map
um right so a map is an augmenter
because I can give you a map and you can
look at it Sean and say you know
I can take it away from you and you
still preserve elements of that map in
your imagination
um whereas with the GPS clear that's not
true
um and I think so there is in this
current moment a way to express what an
llm is in terms of very general
principles of cognitive opacity
and that's been something I've I've been
thinking about wait a minute I think I
understood everything you said except
the relevance of the phrase cognitive
opacity which is the following
um so we now know
that
multi-generational
collectively constructed representations
like number systems
can be internalized by single
individuals right so no one person
invented the Indian Arabic number system
but you have it in your head yeah okay
so there's this very interesting Dynamic
that goes on
um and part of why that's possible is
because you can reason through numbers
um you know what their compositional
rules are you know what place value
numbers are and so on and the same is
true of the Abacus and so on
um with large language models that's not
true there is you could use that forever
and never internalize it why is that and
it's not just a dimension
um that's why mechanism is so important
in scientific theory it's the reason you
were able to learn classical mechanics
general relativity is because you
deliberated through the mechanics
um that's how you came to encode it
internally you didn't just copy and
paste it from Jim hoddle's textbook
right you know that's not how Learning
Works
um whereas in this case we can't and so
it occupies a category of and well
that's why I say cognitive opacity yeah
like other artifacts also occupy
incidentally that aren't as powerful
like a GPS
um and theorizing about the the
properties
of artifacts that can be decomposed and
replicated in the Mind's Eye uh versus
those that cannot is it is a is a
theoretical challenge I like it it's a
great example of how this highfalutin
theorizing matters to issues of the real
world that we're going to be confronting
like it or not very soon
it is and interestingly in 1950 I don't
know if you know this philosopher I love
him Henry marginal I know his name he
wrote a book called The Nature physical
reality it's a it's a he tried to
elaborate on the concept of the schema
and he called it the construct I'm very
fond of this idea and the basic idea is
he that a good theory should have
certain properties and he enumerates
them
um and I I didn't even go through it but
if things like they should be causal
they should be minimal
um they should be extensible so you can
imply that the concept of entropy to a
bridge as well as to a body right
um they should be fertile uh by that he
meant composable anyway
um and it turns out that all good
theories have construct properties and
it helps us learn them llms aren't con
they might contain constructs that we
don't know yeah and and so I I yes it if
you're interested in human flourishing
then I think the kinds of things that we
do matter that way I realize that in
fact I was reading Henry marginal's name
earlier today in the context of him
complaining about what a terrible Theory
the Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics that's right that's so good
yeah Murray would have loved him yeah
exactly okay well I'm sorry we didn't
get a chance to go on about intelligence
for hours because I'm sure we could but
we'll point to your web page and people
can find the work but okay so let's
we've covered a lot of ground I I guess
I want to wrap up with you know the big
thoughts on the future of the field I I
have the impression that
40 years ago the founding of SFI you
know there was this idea that that we
would sit down and Define complexity and
then find the rules that it obeyed and
uh whether or not that has actually
happened a lot of the success of SFI or
other institutes around the world has
really been in you know a more piecemeal
approach to understanding various
obviously complex phenomena and thinking
about them in a more General way do you
do you foresee a ultimate coming
together in coherence of you know the
theory of complexity on a t-shirt or
will the theory of complexity itself
become ever more complex I don't know
spot I don't but I'm not dodging it I
think it's a very good question it's
just that I do think if I look at the
work of you know
ulam Von Neumann
Conway on automata I think God that's
rich and now and more recently Stephen
Wolfram that's fascinating you look at
the work on hydrodynamics and chaos and
you look at the work on now increasingly
um non-equilibrium statistical mechanics
advances in evolutionary Dynamics it
does feel as if there's an awful lot of
synthesis to be done
um and we have meetings as you know you
come to many of them where there are
tantralizing Clues
um that connect that established Bridges
um between these fields so I think there
will be a lot of unification
um I don't think it will be on one
t-shirt I and I think that's because
we're you know
not in the Warren Weaver World we're not
in the world of Maxwell's equations
we're in that world the komogorov
described as having large description
length and it might be in your wardrobe
maybe spread out with several different
agents of clothing including my socks
yeah but I don't think it'll be on a
single t-shirt and I think
um hence our interest in algorithms
right and code and and and and
alternative formal languages
um that's one side of it so I'm very
optimistic about synthesis but I I don't
think it will be
in that sort of super Occam form that
we've got used to
um but as important as and I know this
again is an Institute of yours um a
deeper more principled understanding of
society um
of political institutions economic
structures
it's quite clear that we got here by
accident
we stumbled into the modern world and
we're stumbling all over it and I and I
do believe that new ideas are required
actually
um and I'm not saying they'll just come
from science I'm sure they'll come from
philosophy and politics and literature
um but that kind of consilience
um I'm also optimistic about and as long
as we're
generous
with other fields and
um and not excessively epistemologically
greedy which I think we can be actually
well um yeah I mean that does lead me to
the last question that I have since as
well as being an accomplished scientist
you're also the president of the Santa
Fe Institute which is uh I'm sure almost
all my listeners know about it since I'm
fractal faculty there but it is a little
Utopia in the mountains where people
come together to think about large
interdisciplinary questions and to me
the success of this approach is just
obvious and and compelling and
intoxicating and yet it has not taken
over the world like there's other places
that are still resistant to thinking
about
complexity or in complex systems for its
own sake do you do you perceive reasons
why that's the case is this just the
stodginess of Academia in general or is
it is it something deeper than that I
think there are many factors uh many and
um
some negative and some positive the the
negative ones are obvious right
territoriality resistance to change
fear of not being the master kind of
moving
um and which is a professional
defamation of experts
um on the other side SFI is a kind of
weird laboratory that generates variance
but doesn't breed them we don't scale
if we scale you'd hate it but you know
it wouldn't have that delightful
property that you like right we all know
each other we all bump into each other
and I think that what happens at SFI
very naturally is that successful
projects go elsewhere to scale and
um and the problem with that
institutionally it's not a problem I
don't think russify but to answer your
question why is it rare is that money
moves towards larger projects closer to
execution and
um so where small scrappy little outfit
in the mountains a bunch of weird monks
nuns running around
um
you know on a dime yeah and I think
that's important in a way and um if if a
project were to become very successful
you'd have to build we don't allow
groups for example groups are prohibited
there can't be the Sean Carroll group or
something there's you and there's me and
there's a bunch of our friends and we
argue with each other and
um if you want to go and scale your
research project which you might need to
incidentally if you're working in
Neuroscience or God knows watch uh but
then you go somewhere else and I think
that the culture of parsimony
and um early phase Venture is not what
funding particularly likes or what
scientists particularly like and
um so and that's okay because I think
it's dispositional and and you're a good
example look Sean I mean you you have
the best of both worlds right you can
you can move through
I'm
I'm I think I have some congenital
dislike of large institutions so I I
don't go there and that's probably true
for some of my colleagues here who are
here the whole time but so I think that
combination of the way that science is
supported the way it's rewarded largely
through scaling
um and then the disposition to enjoy the
uncertainty of startup which is what we
are that those and you multiply them
together with some other terms and then
you explain why we're rare I like it I
like it very much I do have the best of
both worlds so I am fortunate and I I
recognized and privileged but here's to
the scrappy band of Misfits of the monks
and nuns running amok I think that great
things are going to be coming in the
future and David krakower thanks so much
for being on the mindscape podcast
wonderful thank you Sean
[Music]